like i try to make it fast like if i see
a girl drinking at a bar right
i'll go up behind her i'll go i'll go i
can get us a bottle
and that doesn't work very often but
sometimes
right yeah i want to get ready then i
get the ladies
i turn off all the lights in the room so
it's pitch black
and then i lay down on top
for five ten minutes there's just a
difference between girls and women there
is that's why they call it girls gone
wild
there's no women gone wild
nobody's ordering the women gone wild
tapes
because when girls go wild they show
their tits to people
when women go wild they kill men
and they drown their kids in a tub
that's what wild women do
so what exactly is a hot girl
it's like being yourself yeah a man
you're confident you're happy you're
doing your thing and in school you know
how to live the best of both worlds
there's no guys and i mean
obviously that you know there's some
guys involved
so no dick involved there doesn't have
to be it could
that is a good question i'm gonna tell
you why that's a good question and i
thought you
have a voice i thought about this it
needs to be okay
no vagina listen all you hot girls hot
girls and city girls need to listen up
to this right who taylor want a piece
hot girls in cities
i've never heard that definition of hot
girl city okay what i've heard about hot
girl city girl is that they're
girls who don't give a [ __ ] about what
these guys talking about they running
through these guys this summer
they [ __ ] who they want to love they
live in their best life hot girl city
girl is separate
okay so the city girls are scammers you
know okay
who are they scamming men okay so you
need men
hot girls is not what hot girls doing
about yourself you have a
gun it doesn't involve so hot girls have
nothing to do with [ __ ] whoever you
want to [ __ ]
no yeah that's different from city girl
city girls so city girls is [ __ ]
everybody
seasons two different summers so the
city girls need men the hot girls don't
who okay again let me just clarify here
so
you have the hot girls
no sorry city girls they they need the
men
right and then hot girls are lesbians is
that what you were saying no
that's what i'm hearing yeah i'm
confused
we just need each other we just eat
[ __ ]
and he just has to learn that like young
people can take this advice if they want
to
but if you haven't lived any pain if you
haven't
like said what the [ __ ] man if you're
not tired
this is a show for [ __ ] who are
tired of not being
happy and not understanding the the
thing that's calling in their gut like
their gut
they don't understand something sitting
there and you're like
i hate this [ __ ] i don't know
what i don't know why what the [ __ ]
like you don't get it joe might have a
chance to avoid that pain
there's no way that you have to fall
asleep have you avoided it
well no because do you know anybody
that's avoiding it it's
you don't have a statement that
completely
disagrees with me and then when i say
something that makes sense you [ __ ]
didn't agree with me
blow it off like you made it up yourself
and then go to another subject
so you see what she did there why are
you throwing it down see what she just
did
she went diversion this [ __ ] just uses
the jedi mantra
she goes one plus one equals two
i said no you can scream yes it does but
c4
is not an even number what you
think i'm a master at this [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] this i'm saying
but just throwing things if if i was in
love with carys
drive you crazy i would that these guys
out here
are [ __ ] dealing with because they
they love her so if you love a [ __ ] you
gotta hear her
horseshit and let her keep going my girl
just wants to tell stories now
and have me not interrupt just [ __ ]
tell stories and then i i was watching i
was i'm getting my truck fixed
i'm going to the place and i'm [ __ ]
looking at all my children my girl does
these soaps right
so i call she she does she'll do one
like extra work on soap sometime or
she even had a like actual part on what
i'm talking
so i call i go these [ __ ] soap stink
because that's what was playing in the
weight room right
she goes yeah but you know why because
see soaks
you know where soap's the acting
technique came from she so wants to
tell me something it's like from
broadway it's a broadway scene
and i'm like i don't give a [ __ ]
but to her credit she knows now she
innately
has put me as an option to say wait a
minute
this story [ __ ] stinks
she's self-governing now
that is so sad that is so sad no it's
not yes it is because she's trying to
share a part of herself in her life with
you
how that's how we communicate how often
how often a guy would a guy edit guys
edit themselves with women all the time
no but if they well it's still
self-editing it's the same thing if you
if a chick says she's
she's how do i look in this am i fat and
this he goes oh
but it's about communicating you go yeah
you look fat and then it's over with
it's about communicating and we just
want to share with you because that's
what we do we are communicators
we talk you're not communicators you
know what you are you're [ __ ] talkers
communicators actually put something in
my head
with the with see men's value men are
actually trying to
do that though you're just you're just
gonna hear what you're saying right
that's the point
yourself it's valuable to who us there
you go
now we're gonna take another call
um okay olive garden chronicles
hey billy boy i am a 24 year old
part-time college student
working at olive garden and this new
chick here has been a real flirt towards
me
uh i see just about all the signs she
always tells me how delicious
i smell gross how bad she wants to play
with my hair
okay one time when i was testing out a
drink she took the glass rotated to the
part where my
mouth wasn't drank on it from there
disgusting
all right so you know she swallows
um so what do you plan on taking old ass
to mouth
sorry uh for some reason i found that
hot
oh this guy's [ __ ] hilarious
everything about her was
was uh everything about it was
incredible figure nice tits and
glasses made her look even sexier with
her pinned up hair one big
problem this is a game changer she's 17.
oh dee dude she's got major [ __ ]
daddy issues
come on dude there's plenty of [ __ ]
that are of age
uh do i really need to read the rest of
this
we got off at the same time the other
night and just started talking outside
oh
dude if this [ __ ] goes to some sexual
thing if i read it is am i part of the
[ __ ] crime
is 17 legal in your state some states it
is just a good old boy
um i did the gentleman thing and asked
her if she needed a ride home
[ __ ] you you [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't lie to me huh i thought we were
friends
calling me up you're asking for advice
and then you 40 think i'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you didn't do the gentleman thing your
dick was [ __ ] pushing through your
zipper
and you're like you want to ride home
you want to [ __ ] ruin this girl
tried to do the generally thing you [ __ ]
you know what i
just for that i shouldn't even read the
rest of this but i'm too [ __ ]
interested
um she politely declined and said her
sister wants to pick her up
adding that she doesn't want to use me
like that she also said she was afraid
that she might get you
used to it and expect it every time we
work together
understandable it's not understandable
she's [ __ ]
jerking you around she's putting on a
goddamn
[ __ ] pg-13 sex show
you know inside the bar and then you get
outside hey there's my car you want to
just [ __ ]
continue on with your little show no
that's okay
this might be one of these girls that
get your dick [ __ ] you know
hard as a [ __ ] rock and then just
walks away just wants to see you chase
it and the only way you're going to get
it is if you just [ __ ] walk away from
it and she'll follow you home like a
lost puppy but she's 17. so you don't
want that to happen
anyways however she asked me to stick
around and keep her company till her
ride comes
she asked me where i usually hang out
dude can i am i get in trouble for this
[ __ ] i'm not reading the rest of this
she's always
she's only 17. why don't you call kip
winger he'll tell you what the [ __ ] to
do
i say walk away all right
the only question you should be asking
her is when are you turning 18
when she says why say because i'll tell
you on your birthday
[Music]
you